dans morning live sur m6 michaël youn
avait pour habitude d'appeler un homme
et de lui faire vivre l'enfer commence à
peler cet homme est homme s'appelait ans
mais je regardais tout le temps à
l'époque man comment ça peut sortir
s'ouvre sur fond de ballades c'était kim
mais bouquet bernard bien sûr c'était
des rares à bernard est bizarre il n'a
pas lâché attaque où je mets mes
personnages de l'émission vous
l'appeliez presque tous les jours dans
une séquence qui s'appelait le médiateur
regarder on a préparé une petite compil
alors bernard je crois que vous n'aimez
pas trop notre émission non pas du tout
alors pourquoi essayer de faire un bon
début
c'est carrément débile vous êtes
vraiment un cocon lourd dans la rue mais
peut-être que je descende être trouvée
et trois pagodes bakary koné toi tu te
manquer le temps que je trouvais à
bouffer de la merde
non mais d'abord un cap et un gros merci
beaucoup merci encore il est venu chez
plus la dernière semaine à l'avant
dernière émission puis finalement été
baladé devant les caméras ils étaient
beaucoup plus été exceptionnelle était
beaucoup plus qu'un grand moment de
tableau ce soir sur s'est vite qu'ils
viennent à me taper parle de son salaire
quel chiffre donne t-il aux enfants
entre 1 million et 20 millions plus de
20 millions ou le même salaire que
benjamin castaldi à l'époque de secret
story
quand il était marié à une star de la
télé alors je n'ai vu au tableau
d'ailleurs c'est extraordinaire c'est
entre 1 et 20 millions c'est ce que vous
voulez entre 1 et 20 millions 3,1 et 20
millions et 20 millions c'est ce qui
donne vie mélissa ça l'est moins on
regarde la règle
vous gagnez combien par mois beaucoup
c'est pas un chiffre
un chiffre entrée 1 euro et 20 millions
[Applaudissements]
après dix années entre 1 euro et 20
millions mais voyons passer de la la la
relance de l'enfant ouais elle peut pas
de données par la production j'ai posé
la question ces mines aurizon les
enfants sont maintenant c'est
intéressant nous mêmes en région et est
sûre ils ont pas d'oreillettes et non
pas voir tous les enfants qui ont des
oreilles paraguay mais du coup on n'a
pas de réponse quoi cette mise à jour
qui ont repris mais brut
voilà 17 millions d'euros par an pour
kylie ann m bape et voilà tu vois ta
page et le bon métier sans publicité
mais mon mari
la tête ça fait 1 les filles préfèrent
les filles ont beaucoup changé
[Rires]
me connaît bien
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc assez bon avec quelques
chanteurs français michaël youn at il
enregistré la chanson mauvaise foi
nocturne pascal guilbault florent pagny
patrick vincent passé alors mauvaise foi
nocturne s'est bien entendu francky
vincent a fait exprès je vois tu fais
exprès je fais pas exprès mais j'ai pas
de mémoire des sens la cdu marc mémoire
des sens tout promettre halte à la
mémoire des sons qu'elles sont posé une
question en garde suit raconte
pourquoi toute cette violence est rien
fait moi aujourd'hui je cette fiche est
parce qu elle coûter chez moi en tout
cas j'étais c'était par le témoin
quels éléments qu'il ya trois ans basic
dégâts challenge où selon elles sont
hors des murs et toits merkel et ça
s'applique jan aps le doigt tendu comme
un string à pékin que quoi
en plus d'eux
mais j'avais très peur
[Applaudissements]
mais cette fois la parade est meilleur
que l'original ou alors combien les deux
étaient bonnes j'ai fait après c'est
toujours plus aux enchères à des
pandémies non parce que elle était très
bonne aussi la venue sur le rap non
mediative ita c'était très bien mais là
ça fait du bien aussi sa mauvaise foi
nocturne ne veut pas dire qu'une parodie
est mieux que l'original saisirait pas
de parodies sur l'original donc ben
voilà on est les deux arrêtez de vous
prendre la tête pour nous c'est bon
quelle émission m'a parlé du pull soit
non il est beau j'aime beaucoup
isabelle vous êtes très sexy et de plus
en plus belle j'ai carrément vous dire
panna cotta panna cotta un langage codé
parce que fournir tous les locaux d'un
mois chez elle d'accord a fait l'amour
avec son pareil on se fait une panacotta
exactement voilà par le hondurien
benjamin castaldi il dit j'appelle
toutes mes ex c'est moche ça tous les
jours
ja dézéry comme ça t'as pas besoin
d'ennemis ça va c'est moi l émission
mélissa theuriau at elle refusé de
présenter à la rentrée dernière passe
neige alors journal du hard
alors un petit peu de respect s'il vous
plaît pourquoi non mais ça qui est des
gens très bien qui le représente alors
quoi messi ouvrait journal travailler
dans les médias
ouais alors là la belle imposture se
révèle mathieu family est une amie mais
c'est à vous alors c'est mélissa oui
c'est à vous mais là non
c'est diaby ou des petits noms
d'ailleurs vous avez avoué à nos
confrères d'rtl est vrai que la
production pensez à vous avant de
proposer le poste à inhaler anne
elisabeth lemoine et vous l'avez refusé
écouter ce que vous avez dit sur rtl
production de ces travaux a tout fait
pour vous avoir à la présentation de ce
magazine alors qu'anne sophie lapix
partait pour france 2 vrai ou faux
j'ai discuté avec les producteurs que
jean pierre antoine capton ouais c'était
du sur mesure en plus pour vous pourquoi
ne pas y être non c'est une quotidienne
c'est renoncer à des tas d'autres choses
aussi que je que j'initie vraiment ce
n'est pas rien elle existe déjà et je
pense vraiment je le talent d'année avec
le moine je suis dès les premières et
ses ferventes supportrices à avoir ce
côté qu'elle incarne le programme poté
away mélissa et vous allez avouez que
vous aimeriez bien prendre la place de
laurent delahousse c'est vrai sommet
juste je veux préciser très long et
confus à ce truc certaine mais j'ai pas
refuser les parents refusent émission
car alors il fallait bien un ouais je
parle régulièrement avec le producteur
avec la main donne car en toile et il me
l'a proposé à plein de moments même
avant que n'ait jamais refusé lapix ya
eu d'ailleurs mais mais là en
l'occurrence non c'était vraiment un
elisabeth lemoine qui était pressenti
droit s'est sentie choisi c'est un très
bon choix que j'ai que j'ai salué
immédiatement et je trouve que est sûre
laurent delahousse est vrai que vous
abordiez prendre la place de laurent
delahousse
alors non j'ai pas dit ça non plus voilà
interrogé sur des programmes que j'aime
et où des veaux change de type ii
plateaux et j'ai cité ce que fait
laurent delahousse après son jt de 20
heures le dimanche de 106 démission
voilà ouais en tout cas ce moment de
débat culturel où il réunit deux
personnes je trouve que ça vous plairait
ouais c'est un bon moment mais il
appartient à laurent blanc laurent qui
concerne le jt de forme quand même
beaucoup le polar l'interview par hasard
c'est mélissa theuriau se verrait bien
la place de laurent b vous aimeriez
faire quoi alors mélissa alors je me
verrais pas du tout à la place de la
housse et aujourd'hui je joue bien envie
de regarder leurs aînés les amateurs
voilà à la télé mais en tant qu en tant
que journaliste en tant que
présentatrice ou pas du tout ben non pas
plus que ça puisque ça
ces huit vous a proposé des trucs ou pas
alors ces huit pages tableau ce qui vous
a proposé des caisses qui vous ont
proposé des choses à l'entraînement mais
je suis ravi qu'ils me suivent sur au
tableau et je me réjouis de voir qu'on
va continuer à la rentrée et ça c'est
une grande satisfaction mais vous auriez
pas posé leurs valises pour tous ceux
qui travaillent sur ce programme et à
non à l'antenne il n'est pas question
d'un quart ne me riez pas peuvent
incarner peut-être chez palais les
documentaires de ses 8 où l'info sur
s'est vite neutralisé par le 4 x laïque
et internationaux aux nouvelles mais les
nouveautés initier des atouts mais on
discutera accord discutées va très bien
balou nous peut massage est passée la
direction que c'est vite des massages
passage le massage est passé c'est bon
je vous les préparez vous n'avez plus
qu'à l'accueillir j'adorais voir melli
cinquantaine de cv voilà en effet dans
l'état sauvage avec mike horn
michaël youn a vomi pour quelle raison
parce qu'il a déposé un poulet parce
qu'il a mangé un insecte ou parce qu'il
a vu mike horn nu les vues en plus
j'avais tellement de jouer parce qu'il a
mangé un enseignant les médias mais vous
excusez moi vous êtes ceni c'est
pourquoi et ben non c'est le c'était pas
un poulet pintade
mais c'était la mort c'était dur comme
expérience
oui mais c'était tellement jouissif tu
es beau tu ferais ou noah a home et
d'ailleurs je vais le refaire
non c'est vrai tu as fait leur faire on
est resté très proche avec mike et je
vais le refaire mais peut-être sans
caméra comme ça pour le cuivre à vous de
ces biens ah ouais bah tu peux pas mieux
d'autres personnes matthieu delormeau
n'ont alors pas trop bas il est où
monsieur homais tomber la croma spyker
tu devrais jouer avec moi tu va lancer
je la vois l'apprend mamie non je ne
bois pas je ne dors pas oui mais faut
quand même savoir marcher bella
[Applaudissements]
pardon donc désolé mais il n'y a pas
d'autres bruits qui sort deux mois que
celui là misez pas une poule et qui
arrive sur l'acier comme ça je suis toi
bouchez moi et encore des deux corps
mais c'est pas de tuteur une image plus
tard on à l'heure espagnole au tableau
ce soir sur ses mythes sûr qu'il ya des
maps est dit il prend pour exemple c'est
moi vous allez donner une bonne réponse
à bompas bien sûr j'ai un point
une deuxième sur qui il dit qu'il prend
exemple sur zinedine zidane est pas
possible de dire des conneries il a
décidé de faire tout faux pas ce qu'il
veut absolument faire des tubes y
regarder mais vous pouvez donner une
bonne réponse de temps encore garder une
cause qui vous tient à coeur
oui aider ceux qui sont dans le besoin
parce que j'ai eu mon frère qui a joué
beaucoup plus tôt et ça a toujours été
mon exemple et il a toujours aidé ceux
qui étaient dans le besoin et je me suis
dit que si un jour j'arrive et à devenir
quelqu'un de bien ce serait mieux que
d'être un grand footballeur
[Applaudissements]